The joe rogan experience.
That's what I get.
Probably something something
representative of Chicago back home. Jeff.
Fuck on Chicago.
Deep dish pizza in a broad like get a
old style and a hat dog on my shoulder.
Shit,
a snow shovel and a fucking bratwurst.
He's got a high cholesterol chart
reading everything is up at the top.
Problem problem, but everybody's
fine. Don't worry about it.
Everyone's got affect gut
and then find in a big smile.
Heard you making fun or Joe
Rogan's making fun of us stone.
I don't like that and she
can't go tell him to fuck off.
That's what I say to Joe Rogan.
Swell.
Boycott your fucking shitty show on
June 8th hey is your [inaudible],
is Joe Rogan in? No. Seth Rogan's to
get a broader Joe Rogan. They know it.
They don't each other these different
than that other guy. Different guy.
Seth Rogen. He not fake.
Got Mad at me. He goes,
everyone spells my name wrong cause
are you sorry dude. Who is this?
A dumb way of spelling it.
You got to stop using an e at the end.
Rogin rock n route again.
It's Rogan.
Rogan Gan to English. Mine's
Irish. His his English.
But do you see this crazy as
fuck? Yeah. This is $500 uh,
gravity bomb.
It's a little too much for a gravity bong,
but it's just smoke a joint.
$500 for gravity. Bong. I
look at it. It looks crazy.
Yeah. She shares with a real
good idea. Look, we want to joint
wash and flipped it looked at, he flips
his shit right upstairs in the lighter.
Yeah. Gas Station. Lighter joint.
We're good. You don't need a $500 bond.
Seth Rogan so serious.
I handed him stoner of the year award
once one of the high times awards,
500 bucks out of the woods.
That's ridiculous.
People are always trying to
give me these fucking things.
Did you get stoner of the year award?
Yeah, I got it once right? Did I get it?
They were offering it to me.
I think I might have had to go to get it.
As you said, you probably
were like, I can't go a man.
Yeah, I'm Muslim. Gonna go.
I'm not going to say I can't go. I hosted
the doobies one year, which was fun.
It was like an award show that was
in like 2001 yeah. And then uh,
I gave an award to Seth
Rogan and another time,
but they've asked me to perform at
those before and I did it once where the
doobies it's just everyone's
high as a kite. It's all weird.
It's this, I mean you
just, there's so out of it.
Crazy show ever. It's the
underground comedy show in Toronto.
Do you haven't done that place dude,
they have a bong shop and in the
back room it's all a comedy show,
but it's all people
smoking pot in the room.
It's a hot button while
you're doing the show. Yeah,
they have bongs on the tables,
dude. People are blitzkrieg.
You are so high when you're on stage,
you can't remember what you were
talking about three seconds ago.
I mean it's so bad and it's thick.
Like smoke everywhere. Like the hope,
there's no ventilation you
kit to material. You just
have to go fuck around. Yeah.
I mean you could try to do material.
I definitely have tried,
but like I took Tripoli there
and AAA doesn't really get high.
At least he didn't, I don't
know. I don't think he does time.
I think he might've been sober,
but dude,
he got blitzkrieg just breathing the
air in this place got fucking ripped.
The whole, the whole place is bomb.
There was, I don't think it was a,
I don't think anyone bombed
bombed venue where you're like,
I'm never going to do well in here.
They don't fucking,
they're not paying attention. You're just
out of it. It's just the whole thing.
You're off, everything's
off right. You're so high.
But that's also where I did a thing on
the iron sheik came on stage and that
place he ever seen a video of the Iron
Sheik Joe Rogan's and he starts talking
to me and that's when I realized
the price that pro wrestlers pay,
like the health, like this poor
fellows in crutches and shit,
he can barely walk.
That's him and me on stage
chocolate.
The toughest for the Olympics
is freestyle wrestling serve.
I'm 30
know to
one of the highlights.
Lots
of my life being on stage.
Hi is giraffe pussy talking to the iron
cheek in a room with a pot leaf behind
me. That's a big old pot
leaf. Was He ripped to sober?
I in the house? There was no one
sober in that place. I don't, I don't.
I literally don't think it would be
possible to be sober in that room.
I just don't think you could be. There's
no air in that room. They trap you. Yeah.
I like all the fire.
There's fire like they are little
candles and stuff on a table,
like it's running on air.
They don't have any air to stay lit.
The flame is flickering out.
It's all, we had smoke in here.
Everybody's like lists. Like the whole
idea is less candles burn on weed. Joe.
It's fine, but the shows, they're always
real weird. People go there and just,
it's in Vancouver? No, it's
Toronto. Toronto, Toronto.
I forget what it's called.
Comedy underground. Something like
that. Puff Puff Mama around comedy club.
Underground comedy club.
Yeah.
We've done it a couple of times and
he's still doing shows and shit there.
I don't know. I think so.
Yeah. They don't give up.
They forgot every time they get to high,
they forgot they got through high.
We had to stop it, but we didn't
remember. Dude, who's coming up there?
Give them a plug. Underground comedy
Puff Mama. Dot. Ca. There you go. Fun,
fun place though. And very, very
nice people did it a few times. Dope.
And they did tell a bunch of people
that I was coming and it wasn't coming.
And then people got mad at me and like,
Hey, Yay. I didn't fucking sales coming.
Somebody set a fire in there somewhere.
Promotes your shit, and you're like,
did I say it or did you
hear it from another party?
You didn't hear me promising you fucking
which you going to be there, bro.
We booked tickets, this chores before
Joel get tickets. Which your older boys.
Hey, just so many people. There's
just so many people in the worship.
Okay.